in 1947 the Tranquil town of Maine is
rocked by a shocking murder the prime
suspect in the case is a local Banker
named Andy du fresna despite his
vehement protests of Innocence the court
convicts him and sentences him to two
consecutive life sentences Andy is sent
to shash shank prison a notorious
institution that is known for breaking
even the strongest of men meanwhile red
a convicted killer is interviewed for
parole after spending 20 years in
Shashank despite his sincere efforts to
show that he has turned over a new Le
the parole board rejects his plea
disheartened red returns to his routine
in prison which involves smuggling in
Contraband items for his fellow inmates
in exchange for money when a new batch
of inmates arrives at Shashank red and
his friends place bets on who will crack
under the immense pressure of prison
life red places his wager on Andy he
seems calm and composed on the surface
but Harbors a deep sense of Despair
inside however it is not Andy but an
obese inmate who breaks down and cries
uncontrollably on his first night the
inmates cries attract the attention of
Captain Hadley a sadistic guard who
takes pleasure in brutalizing the
prisoners Hadley unleashes his fury on
the hapless man beating him mercilessly
for hours the following morning the
inmates learned that the obese guy died
in the infirmary from his injuries as
the prison doctor was out for the night
this stuns Andy and he tries to ask
about the man's name but everyone tells
him to mind his own business a month
passes by and one day Andy approaches
red after hearing that he can smuggle
things into the prison he asks red to
get him a rock hammer saying he wants it
to pursue his hobby of collecting and
sculpting rocks red wonders if he
intends to use the hammer to engineer
and Escape but Andy laughs off the
suggestion so red accepts the order but
also warns Andy about the sisters led by
bogs who assault other prisoners soon it
becomes clear that bogs has a major
crush on Andy during the first two
nights of his incarceration Andy spends
most of his time working in the laundry
or fighting off bogs and the sisters
despite the hardships he finds solace in
his friendship with red together they
pass their their time in conversation
sharing their hopes and dreams when a
job vacancy to Tar the roof of a prison
building is announced red pulls some
strings to get Andy and their other
friends on the job one day Andy
overhears Hadley complaining about
having to pay taxes for an upcoming
inheritance using his extensive
experience as a banker he advises Hadley
to shelter his money from the IRS by
turning it into a one-time gift for his
wife he also offers to help him file the
paperwork in exchange for chilled beers
for his fellow inmates the Arrogant
Captain appears to be angry at first but
after seeing Andy's intelligence he
agrees to the deal over time Andy builds
good relations with everyone in the
prison making him more comfortable and
confident he also starts to read and
increases his knowledge sometime later
he approaches red with another strange
demand he wants a poster of the actress
Rita Hayworth red is definitely a bit
weirded out by it but nonetheless he
agrees without asking anything H I guess
she was hot in the 40s later Andy runs
into the sisters who again try to force
themselves on him but this time he
confidently challenges them saying he
isn't afraid to die he even threatens to
bite off their manhoods if they come any
closer to him I'll bite you I'll bite
your dicks the sisters are taken aback
by his courage and so they decide
against testing his threat however they
beat him to a pulp putting him in the
infirmary for a month as a result bogs
is given solitary confinement and when
he comes out he is beaten by Hadley and
his men the beating is so severe that he
permanently becomes handicapped and is
transferred to a prison hospital boog's
gang members also move on and leave Andy
alone for good when Andy is finally
released from the infirmary red and the
others gift him a bunch of sculptable
rocks and a giant poster of Rita
Hayworth soon Warden Samuel Norton
learns about Andy's skills and uses a
surprise cell inspection to meet him he
finds him reading the Bible and
discusses his favorite verses as the
guards turn the cell upside down for
smuggled Goods after failing to find
anything illegal Norton encourages Andy
to keep reading the Bible saying that
salvation lies within later Andy learns
that he has been assigned to work in the
prison Library as the assistant of an
aging inmate Brooks Halton in return He
he gives Financial advice to the prison
guards and helps them file their income
tax returns I wish I was in prison with
Andy one day he gets an idea to expand
the prison library to help other inmates
broaden their Horizons on Norton's
advice he asks the main state senate for
funds by writing letters every week over
time he becomes so popular that even the
guards from other prisons seek his
service when they visit Shashank for an
inter prison baseball tournament Andy
also becomes Norton's personal financial
adviser one day something takes over
Brooks and he holds an inmate hostage
threatening to kill him it's then
revealed that Brooks after serving a
staggering 50 years behind bars is due
to be released from Shashank prison but
as the reality of Freedom looms before
him he finds himself unable to cope with
the outside world he feels lost
terrified and alone convinced that he
will never be able to adapt to life on
the outside in a desperate attempt to
cling onto the only life he's ever known
Brooks resorts to drastic measures
taking a fellow prisoner hostage but in
the midst of the chaos Andy steps
forward and convinces Brooks to calm
down he reminds him that there's still a
whole world waiting for him Beyond The
Prison Walls later Andy discusses the
incident with red and the latter
comments that Brooks has become
institutionalized after spending 50
years at Shashank he has become
essentially conditioned to be a prisoner
for the rest of his life and is unable
to adapt to the outside world red says
that these walls are funny first you
hate them then you get used to them
enough time passes you get so you depend
on him in the next scene Brooks is
eventually paroled despite his wish to
continue staying at the prison as he
steps out he stares in awe at the
Towering buildings and bustling crowds
feeling overwhelmed by the sudden change
of environment he has no family or
friends waiting for him no place to call
home and no purpose to live for the only
thing familiar to him is his old routine
the routine of a prisoner and the
memories of the shash shank prison flood
his mind desperate to cling onto
something familiar Brooks takes up a job
at a local supermarket but he finds
himself struggling to keep up with the
fast pace and demands of the outside
world people around him talk and behave
differently and he cannot seem to
understand their ways As Days Go By
Brooks's depression deepens and he
begins to feel hopeless about his future
finally unable to cope with the
overwhelming emotions Brooks commits the
unthinkable leaving behind a message
Brooks was here on the wooden beam six
long and grueling years pass by and
Andy's persistence in writing letters to
the state legislature finally pays off
the prison has granted $200 to fund the
expansion of the library along with a
collection of old and tattered books and
phonograph records among them Andy
discovers a copy of Mozart's The
Marriage of Figaro determined to share
this musical Masterpiece with his fellow
inmates Andy devises a risky plan while
working in the warden's office he seizes
the opportunity to lock the guard in the
washroom and play the record over the
prison's loudspeaker system as the notes
of the Opera fill the stale air of the
prison an extraordinary thing happens
the inmates including the toughest of
criminals are Swept Away by the beauty
of the music even the guards can't help
but smile at the sheer power of the
performance unfortunately Andy's Act of
defiance doesn't go unnoticed and he is
sentenced to 2 weeks in solitary
confinement despite the punishment he
remains steadfast in his belief that
hope is the key to survival and he
refuses to let the brutal conditions of
Shashank break him sometime later red
appears for yet another parole hearing
after living in prison for 30 years
unfortunately the authorities once again
reject him to cheer him up and he gives
him a harmonica to mark his 30 years in
return Red gives him a giant poster of
Marilyn Monroe to commemorate his 10
years here you go you pervert after the
Mozart incident the state gives Andy a
budget of $500 to expand the library he
uses the meager fund wisely and signs
deals with book clubs and Charities to
create the best prison library in Maine
and names it after the late Brooks with
the improved infrastructure Andy starts
to tutor inmates who wish to get their
High School diplomas so that they can
get decent jobs when they are released
from prison meanwhile the warden
enriches himself by exploiting Andy's
knowledge and banking expertise soon he
begins profiting by forcing the inmates
as cheap laborers for public projects
which he easily wins by outbidding his
competitors to hide Norton's ill-gotten
wealth from the law and he sets up
accounts in several Banks using the
identity of an imaginary man Randall
Stevens who only exists on paper and he
created this fake user with his
extensive knowledge of the system and
male ordered forms although Randall
Stevens doesn't exist in real life he
has a birth certificate social security
number and driving license the plan is
foolproof and if the law ever
investigates the matter they will chase
a man that only exists on paper the
movie then fast forwards to the year
1965 a young man named Tommy is
sentenced to 2 years at Shashank for
breaking and entering Tommy is a fun and
charismatic man he has been going in and
out of jail since he was 13 years old he
soon befriends Andy and red and the
three form a cohesive Bond one day Tommy
asks Andy to help him in earning his
high school equivalency diploma the
latter immediately agrees and hence they
start their preparations after months of
hard work and perseverance Tommy
eventually sits for the exam however by
the end of the test he gets frustrated
over his performance and tosses his
answer sheet in the trash nevertheless
Andy retrieves it and sends it to the
education board in the next scene red
confronts Tommy and berates him for his
recklessness reminding him of the time
and effort Andy has invested in helping
him earn his high school equivalency
diploma don't be a dumb Tommy
finally realizes the gravity of his
mistake and apologizes then he drops a
bombshell during his time at another
prison he shared a cell with a man who
had confessed to killing a ER and his
lover the man frequently bragged about
how he framed an innocent Banker for it
hearing this Andy is taken aback as he
realizes that the banker is none other
than himself he immediately goes to the
warden to ask for a new trial with Tommy
as a witness however the corrupt Warden
afraid of losing his easy source of
profit refuses to help him and instead
punishes him with a month of solitary
confinement during this time Tommy
receives his high school diploma
unfortunately a few days later he is
escorted out of the prison and and
executed by Hadley to stop him from
helping Andy get out of prison the
warden then visits Andy in solitary
confinement and tells him about Tommy's
passing claiming that he got shot dead
while trying to escape as expected Andy
doesn't buy this and he refuses to help
Norton launder money anymore however the
warden threatens him with dire
consequences including shutting down the
library should he stop working for him
after Andy is released from solitary
confinement he opens up to rad about his
past and the love of his life his late
wife he shares how his work and ambition
drove her away and how he feels
responsible for her death even though he
didn't pull the trigger overwhelmed with
regret and longing Andy Reveals His
Ultimate Dream to Red to escape to a
small Beach town in Mexico called ziua
Tano where he can finally live a
peaceful and simple life he invites red
to join him there one day Andy also
tells him about a specific area in
buckton Maine where he has hidden
something he wants red to retrieve it
when he is released as the days pass by
Andy resumes his Shady work for Norton
and this worries red The Smuggler's
worries are heightened further when he
learns that Andy has asked a fellow
inmate for a 6-ft rope red assumes the
worst and fears that his friend May
commit the unthinkable the next day Andy
doesn't answer the regular Morning Call
and lo and behold it's revealed that he
is missing from his cell soon it is
discovered that he had dug a tunnel
using a jackhammer hidden behind the
poster it turns out he had ordered the
poster to hide the tunnel a flashback
then reveals that he hid the dirt from
the wall in his pockets which he emptied
into the courtyard during his morning
walks the previous night Andy packed
many of Norton's papers and clothes into
a plastic bag which he tied to himself
with the Rope as Norton and others try
to wrap their heads around the Escape
Andy visits all of Norton's Banks posing
as Randall Stevens and withdraws all the
money he also sends a proof of Norton's
illegal Deeds to the National daily not
long after chaos erupts at shash shank
prison as the police and media swarm the
area Hadley is immediately arrested for
the murder of Tommy and the other
corrupt officials are also taken into
custody the evidence that Andy had sent
to the the national daily proves to be
damning and soon the authorities begin
to unravel the web of corruption that
had been woven by Norton and his cohorts
but before the police can arrest Norton
he commits the unthinkable to avoid the
humiliation of being exposed in the end
Justice is served and Andy's Legacy
lives on as a symbol of Hope and
perseverance in the face of Injustice
sometime later red receives an anonymous
postcard from Fort Hancock Texas and his
heart races with anticipation as he
reads it it is a brief message from his
old friend Andy telling him that he
finally made it to his dream destination
ziwa Tano red feels a mix of emotions he
is happy that Andy has achieved his
long-held dream of freedom and starting
a new but at the same time he is sad
that he won't have his friend around
anymore he can't help but wonder how
Andy is fairing if he is happy if he
still thinks about his time in sha shank
as he stares at the postcard he
remembers Andy's words some birds are
not meant to be caged because their
feathers are too bright red Smiles
through his tears knowing that Andy is
one of those birds and feels grateful
for the time they spent together the
scene then cuts to Red's parole Hearing
in 1967 this time he doesn't try to
impress the board instead he tells them
in contempt how rehabilitated is just a
madeup word invented to justify their
having a job he also earnestly expresses
regrets for his actions of the past red
says that he will have to live with that
for the rest of his life at last he asks
the board to stop wasting his time and
to leave him alone to his astonishment
Red's parole is approved this time
around he is then housed in the same
room where Brooks took his own life
moreover red starts working at the same
Supermarket like Brooks there are
moments when he considers committing a
crime so that he can be sent to prison
but every time he remembers the promise
he made to Andy ultimately he visits
buckton and finds the stone wall where
Andy had hidden something it is revealed
to be a small box containing a large sum
of cash and instructions to come find
him in ziwa Tano in the letter Andy says
that he really looks forward to seeing
him as he needs somebody who can get
things for a project of his red finally
realizes the power of Hope and optimism
before leaving he carves a message on
the wooden beam which now says Brooks
was here so was red despite violating
his parole red feels liberated as he
crosses the border at Fort Hancock
leaving behind the oppressive past that
held him back for so long he looks
forward to reuniting with Andy and
embarking on a new adventure knowing
that his friend has given him the gift
of Hope and the strength to pursue his
Dreams the movie ends as the two friends
finally reunite on the Pacific coast
Beach making for a happy ending
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching